[Música]
la llegada de la variante delta al
territorio europeo y los escépticos de
la vacuna dos factores que alertan a la
organización mundial de salud salud con
click al starting to soft en varios
países están empezando a observar una
mayor carga en los hospitales y más
muertes la semana pasada un aumento del
11% en el número de decesos en la región
con una proyección confiable que espera
236 mil muertes en europa para el 1° de
diciembre index in europe by december'
first según a world in their a y el
recuento de la universidad johns hopkins
en el mundo se han producido más de 4.5
millones de decesos de los cuales 1.15
se atribuyen a europa
además 216 millones de personas se han
contagiado en total de los cuales
55.4 millones se dieron en europa
finalmente los europeos según our world
in their a han inoculado a más del 50%
de sus ciudadanos frente al 26% que
registra el mundo en general y aunque la
organización mundial de salud a demos su
preocupación por la propagación de
contagios hay países que ya se acercan a
la nueva normalidad
a partir del 30 de septiembre de este
año se cancelará el fondo solidario y
les recuerdo que las cifras también son
muy claras hubo 500.000 solicitudes de
indemnización del fondo solidario el
pasado mes de mayo y esta cifra habría
bajado a 50 mil por julio es decir una
disminución de 10 veces simplemente
porque el regreso a la normalidad
también se refleja en un menor número de
solicitudes de asistencia
francia habría destinado
283 mil millones de dólares para ayudar
a empresarios duramente afectados por la
pandemia
entretanto en francia siguen protestando
contra el pase sanitario al igual que en
italia grecia y alemania donde hay
muchas personas que no quieren recibir
la vacuna